europa reporta en octubre nueve meses
después de iniciarse la pandemia de
coronavirus más de siete millones de
contagios frente a esta realidad la
unión europea en aras de prevenir una
recesión económica indicó un nuevo
protocolo de viaje dentro del territorio
es difícil saber a dónde puedes viajar y
qué reglas debes seguir cuando llegas a
tu destino la adopción de este protocolo
por parte de los gobiernos nacionales
traerá claridad a las personas basado en
diferentes criterios nuestra propuesta
definirá todas las regiones de la unión
europea basado en el nivel de riesgo
rojo naranja y verde green de esta forma
el mapa codificado con estos tres
colores será producido por el centro
europeo para el control y prevención de
enfermedades con datos que suministren
los 27 gobiernos adscritos semanalmente
los tres criterios son el número de
casos por cada 100.000 habitantes en los
últimos 14 días el número de pruebas por
cada 100.000 habitantes los últimos
siete días para identificar el rango de
testeo general y el porcentaje de
pruebas positivas realizada en la última
semana para determinar el rango de
testeo positivo
los colores que mencionó la presidenta
de la comisión europea se explican en el
siguiente cuadro el color rojo o de alto
riesgo indicaría que hay más de 150
casos positivos en una muestra de 100
mil habitantes el naranja o riesgo medio
determina que existen entre 25 a 150
casos positivos por cada 100.000
habitantes y el color verde o riesgo
bajo fija que hay menos de 25 casos
positivos en la misma muestra la
recomendación tiene como objetivos
asegurar la libertad de movimiento
incrementar la transparencia para los
ciudadanos y las empresas y evitar la
disrupción de servicios dentro de la
unión europea